there are a lot of things that are very
askew with this why is the color
changing why am I being enveloped in an
Instagram filter switch fish these are
not the tones I'm looking for I'll go to
my new version of 50 shades of grey I'll
take it
so I'm clearly not currently in a space
that you are familiar with and that is
because I am in Canada right now the
mild shock abounds I'm in Canada
shooting a secret project I hate saying
that term because it's become such a
thing to say so instead I'm going to
call it and I can't tell you about it
yet adventure and I thought that by this
Friday I would be able to tell you about
it but unfortunately me to wait till
next week to announce it and so I don't
have a friary for you because a lot of
the footage that I was going to use in
Friday hurry would just be too many
spoilers I'm gonna save that for next
week and instead I decided to do a Q&A
do you fault video subject matter so I
went on my Facebook page and I asked you
guys for questions that I can answer
that's right I have a Facebook page and
I hadn't had a Facebook page for a
really long time and it's almost at
50,000 likes so go over there and like
it so that we can have interesting non
consistent times over there I'm trying
I'm trying to make it a fun place for us
to hang out facebook.com slash grace
Helbig but only one a not that many
aides is it that was my boy what is the
current scent around you right now I I
don't know maybe this is why I smell so
bad because I don't know how the smell I
wanted to say
clammy olives but like only just a
slight hint of it not overpowering it
anyway would you rather wrestle a lion
with venom or a snake with a lion's head
because this is a wrestling based
question I think I'd rather tap into why
I'm still alive in a world where those
animals exist tap it out toughen that's
something wrestling MMA UFC a SS how to
deal with stress I don't know it's very
hard to shuffle into the deck have you
met Ali yet the hallowee-- Trinity
it's complete yes I have met Ally Hannah
Hart's new dog Ollie is so so sweet and
weirdly looks like Hannah if Hannah
where dogs got very white skin with pink
undertone very like piercing blue eyes
and just super inquisitive concerned
fearful and slightly like perturbed
eyebrows she made a great choice in pet
are you concerned about your car being
hacked I'm concerned that this might be
some sort of weird threat can you buy me
a pizza can you return one of the many
syllable names you have what the white
rabbit Bartholomew Huntington's the
third that can't be real I see why you
might not have a job that allows you to
get paid that would allow you to buy
your own pizza how do I deal with a girl
I used to like is getting married the
same way I deal with historical facts
forget about them I wish I could
remember which way do you cross your
arms and I'm just pouting like this what
three things would someone need to
summon you if they were doing some sort
of magic ritual
potpourri french fries and a very deep
understanding of personal space name as
many containers as you can in 60 seconds
not a question one your brain it
contains a lot of dumb questions what is
your secret project that you are working
on at least give us a hint I can't tell
you about it yet just yet but stay tuned
next week all will be revealed here's a
hint okay on that nose that ends this
Q&A thank you guys for hanging in and
dealing with this I hope you enjoyed
this video sorry it was kind of a
last-minute scatterbrained thing but I
have fun but that's my body expressing
fun don't forget to like this video and
subscribe if you haven't already because
I'd like to see your user name around
here more often I almost said your face
but I don't know what you look like
maybe you don't have a face that's cool
excellent personal choice stop talking
we need to go we are weak okay I don't
know
are you also terrified of dolphins
please say yes yes their bodies
feel like those bouncy balls that are in
those crates in targets and toy stores
imagine bubbles bouncy balls in those
cages at Toys R Us had awareness
thoughts and an agenda to get at you my
brain is a terrible place